In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 3 on which we commemorate our Holy Father Anatolyus
patriarch of Constantinople.
Saint Anatolyus was from Alexandria and had been ordained deacon by Saint Cyril.
At the time of the robber council of Ephesus in the year 449, he was living in Constantinople
as the representative, Apocryciadios of Dioscarus, patriarch of Alexandria.
Immediately after the assassination of Saint Flavian, Dioscarus, thinking by his intervention
to control the rival C of the capital, had Anatolyus consecrated Archbishop of Constantinople,
but as had happened earlier with Saint Miletios of Antioch, and Saint Cyril of Jerusalem,
the Heretics' expectations were bitterly disappointed, and their favorite candidate suddenly showed
himself a fervent defender of the true faith.
As soon as he ascended the throne, blessed Anatolyus rejected the Heretic Dioscarus, and after
having returned Saint Flavian's name to the diptyx, he translated his body with great honor
to the Church of the Holy Apostles.
He then sent in cyclical letters to all the bishops, urging them to pronounce the Anathema on the
leaders of the Heretics, Nistorius, Utiches, and Dioscarus, as well as all who taught that
the divine nature had suffered commingling or change at the incarnation of the Word of God.
Having greatly contributed to the convoking of the 4th Holy Echumenical Council in the year 451,
in which he played a leading role, he encouraged the Holy Fathers to proclaim clearly
the dogma of the two natures, divine and human, united without division in the unique person
of the incarnate Word. During the eight years of his episcopate, which saw the Church greatly troubled
by reactions following on from the Council, the Holy Prelate, who was humble and gentle like Jacob
the Patriarch, knew nevertheless how to guide his spiritual flock with energy and wisdom.
And thanks to the support of Empress Pulkheria, he encouraged the building of magnificent churches
to the glory of God. During an epidemic, aggravated by a long drought, he took the head of a
precession that passed around the whole capital, and, like a second Moses, prayed on the ramparts
with tears and hands raised to heaven. Almost at once, a violent downpour came to cleanse the town
of its ills and fill the cisterns. Having been healed of an illness by the intercession of St. Daniel
the Stylite, St. Anatolios ardently stood in his defense against those who columnously accused
the holy ascetic of Heresy, and remained one of his most fervent admirers. St. Anatolios convoked a
synod in Constantinople in 457, in order to unathomatize Timothy the Cat, who had been involved in the
assassination of St. Praterius and had seized the sea of Alexandria. Subsequently, he was condemned
to exile by Emperor Leo I. In the following year, St. Anatolios peacefully gave his soul into God's
hands, leaving St. Janadius to succeed him. Through the prayers of our Holy Father's,
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.